Talk a little bit more about what
happens when you open a file,
and how does access
control factor into it.
So, process here is making these
calls we're talking about.
It first opens this file F,
without specifying the mode here,
but maybe this is read.
This line is going from user
to the operating system,
system call,
this is the boundary between the two.
This is untrusted, this is trusted,
as we talked about.
So, this is all in the operating system.
So basically,
the file got stored on the disk, and
files that are actively being accessed,
the operating system keeps track of
those information about a particular
file is in a file control block.
So if you've done
the operating system's class,
you have some idea of how
file systems are implemented.
But for each file that we want
to access, we you know meta-data
that we're talking about for
a file you know what's the file pointer,
where should we read next,
where on disk the file blocks are.
Other kind of information.
We keep track of that in
the file control log.
In Unix, well that's called an i-node,
and there's a table of these.
That's where this i-node table stores
the meta-data about the active or
currently open files.
So this is, here,
I'm saying it file meta-data table.
A file that you're going to
open has to be active,
it it's not active,
it's going to get activated.
So, there's something interesting
happen, when you open a file you tell
the filename, the operating system's
actually is going to go and
say, is this file currently active.
If it is active then there is going to
be a file control block for it, okay.
That's where the meta-data for
this file is going to be.
So a process also has another data
structure that's called an open
file table.
Okay this is kept by
the operating system.
It's per process data
structure we're talking about.
So in this open file
table that we have for
this process that is making
this open call, basically what
we want to do in the open call is that
we want to see if the file is active.
If it is then there is a meta-data
block or file control block for it.
In the open file table, there is
some set of entries that we have.
This is a fixed sized table.
We're going to use one of those entries
to actually store a pointer to this.
And the file descriptor we
return is actually nothing but
an index into this table.
So i is the index in this
table that we're returning.
I think it was about access
check when do we perform.
Actually in Unix-based systems, access
control is done when you open the file.
At the time the file is opened
remember we're going to go in,
we're going to find out if
the file is currently active or
not, we're going to locate its file
into a block where the meta-data is.
In particular the ACL is here too.
With the ACL is here, then it was
nine bits that I was talking about.
Depending on the user or
group the user is part of.
I'm actually going to look at those
ACL bits that we're discussing.
And if the mode here is read, and you
have read information, I do all this.
Okay?
I'm going to grant you access
Mode is right and
the right permission is here.
I'm going to do all of this and
give you write permission and
to place data in this file.
So access check is going to happen
during the open calls execution in
the operating system because we
locate this information where the ACL
information is and
we're going to look that up.
And if everything checks out we set
this up and return this file descriptor.
So the reason we do it at
the time it's open is,
that when you come to read,
you specify a file descriptor.
So, it's going to say read I here,
for exam, that's what you're saying.
Well, once I come to the operating
system, it's the that remember is
an index into a table, that tells me,
it's this particular entry in the table.
Follow the pointer that it points to,
that's where the file meta-data is, and
that tells you where the file data is.
I don't do any access check at
the time I do a read or write.
I just sort of quickly follow these
pointers and get to the file.
If I'm doing reads then I
find the file data to return
to copy that into the buffer.
If I'm doing a write then I copy the
data from the buffer into file cache or
something like that.
It gets copied.
So there's no check done during
either read call or a write call.
The check was done when we did the open,
okay.
So the fact that the script
was returned to you
at that time we did the checking and
now you're able to do that.
If we opened it for read and
you tried to do write, of course.
Of course we're going to stop that.
Okay.
That goes without saying.
We don't have to go look for
the particular to do the transversal
that we are talking about.